é pessoal antes de mais nada o que eu
quero falar uma coisa para vocês eu não
sou bom em nada
é isso mesmo não soube nada pois é essa
é a resposta que eu costumo receber da
maioria dos alunos quando eu pergunto a
eles no que eles são bons no que ele se
destaca em relação a outros alunos
não é qualquer característica marcante
de cada aluno
e essa resposta costuma receber eu não
sou bobo nem nada né meu nome é paulo de
tarso fonseca professor de biologia e há
uns quatro anos junto com outros
professores aqui do colégio nós
começamos a pensar em formas
alternativas de de avaliar novos alunos
formas que fugissem um pouco daquela
prova descritivo então naquela objetiva
mesmo que oferece cinco alternativas
para os alunos cinco alternativas que
foram ali construídas segundo a
interpretação de alguém e o aluno tem
então que se adequará aquelas
alternativas escolher uma delas como
alternativa correta que vai avaliar ele
em relação aquele determinado conteúdo
então depois d de o grupo quebrar
bastante a cabeça
pensamos em usar a arte para avaliar
conteúdos de biologia banana ver vamos
tentar
eu parto do princípio que todos nós
temos nossas habilidades todos nós somos
muito bons em algumas coisas e muito
ruins em outras é água é normal né
todo mundo aqui tem as suas habilidades
vocês aí do lado têm cada um tem a sua
habilidade e aqui também acreditem até
eu tenho as minhas habilidades
artísticas é verdade
cantar é uma delas mentira num canto
essa é a parte que eu sou muito ruim é
então pensamos em trabalhos artísticos e
pensamos em dar liberdade para o aluno
pensar e criar o a forma de apresentar o
conteúdo
então é esse trabalho se apresentava uma
única regra
a única regra era que o conteúdo deveria
ser apresentado através de alguma forma
de expressão artística
qualquer que ela fosse eu até brinco a
gurizada que se conseguirmos explicar o
conteúdo através de sapateado
o trabalho vai ser aceita é tão regra
definida
um dia estava numa turma fazendo as
combinações lima levantou a mão e
comentou
mas paulo eu não sei o que fazer com
tanta liberdade pessoal nesse dia foi eu
acabei recebendo a maior crítica que eu
poderia receber em relação a como nós
estamos acostumados a aprender
nesse momento eu percebi que a gente
aprende por repetição a gente é
apresentado o conteúdo a gente leu o
conteúdo
a gente grava o conteúdo para esse
conteúdo é ser testado em uma prova
então a gente repete é o que a gente vê
hoje em dia a gente sabe que é em alguns
conteúdos o aluno dar uma estudada de
cora vai para a prova faz a prova não
passa na prova tudo bem
em relação àquele conteúdo né taptu aí
no ano seguinte vai falar com o aluno a
alto lembra no passado nós estudamos
nematelmintos né os vermes não pára
nunca vi isso na minha vida então o
aluno demonstra que ele estudar para a
prova e não estou grávida dele
ele está estudando a prova passa
dependendo do conteúdo conteúdo é
deletado da vida do aluno
e aí ficam acumuladas que vão interferir
muito né
no futuro do aluno tão bom beleza né as
primeiras reflexões foram surgindo e
começaram a chegar os primeiros
trabalhos
nunca vou me esquecer o primeiro
trabalho que eu recebi e fui apresentar
para uma turma
os trabalhos são apresentados nessa
turma foi uma música falava sobre
inquilino smo uma relação ecológica né
entre espécies uma usa outra como
suporte no caso das orquídeas
então era uma música quando dei o play
na música
aconteceu uma coisa muito estranha a
turma inteira já sabia cantar música
fiquei pensando como assim
estou apresentando o trabalho agora como
tatu não sabe cantar música
aí eu perguntei é como você sabe a letra
desse trabalho e não esse trabalho foi
colocado no facebook no começo da semana
aí o pessoal compartilhou e todo mundo
conhece já pra mim foi estranho porque
se o aluno está mostrando seu trabalho
de seus colegas é porque tem orgulho do
trabalho
ninguém quer expor as suas vergonhas né
gente expõe que nos causa orgulho que né
o que o que nos orgulha mesmo essa foi
uma outra reflexão se humano tem orgulho
do trabalho é porque ele percebeu que
foi um trabalho bem feito
ele se empenhou para fazer aquele
trabalho então um trabalho que surgiu
como uma avaliação alternativa veja
talvez até para sair da rotina de uma
prova descritiva né objetiva começou a
se mostrar como um ótimo instrumento
para que os alunos pudessem se exercitar
sua criatividade que eles pudessem
demonstrar suas habilidades né
e aí foi o ponto chave da nossa
descoberta e nós descobrimos que esses
trabalhos não avaliavam só é não
exercitavam só o estudo em relação ao
conteúdo trabalhavam também a autoestima
de alguns alunos alunos bem
introspectivos mesmo né alunos que ficam
mais escondidos na sala de aula através
desse tipo de trabalho eles tiveram a
oportunidade de compartilhar as suas
habilidades com os colegas e na minha
opinião esse foi o ponto chave foi o
grande ganho que a gente teve como como
grupo
quando um aluno compartilha sua
habilidade perante seus colegas ele
acaba se tornando referência da turma em
relação à qualidade
ele é a referência isso faz com que eles
pertencem daquele grupo ele pode
colaborar com o grupo se alguém precisar
saber um pouco mais sobre determinada
habilidade vai até ele pediu um conselho
e pedir uma ajuda é essa é a base do
trabalho colaborativo né
na minha opinião o trabalho colaborativo
não é juntar um monte de gente e todo
mundo fazia exatamente a mesma coisa na
minha opinião a ideia é que os pontos
fortes se somem em um trabalho
colaborativo
se é pra fazer a mesma coisa eu posso
fazer sozinho né então pontos fortes
somados geram um resultado muito
superior a esses é alunos bem em
prospect vos eles acabaram em
determinadas situações e melhorando a
relação com a turma já que a turma de
metrô admiração em relação a esses
alunos em relação a mim também porque na
maioria dos trabalhos
eu não tinha nem ideia como eles tinham
sido feitos
eu não possuía aquela habilidade tem
trabalho que apresenta um edição de
vídeo e nível profissional melhor do que
muito material que eu já vi na tv
passando em canal famoso aí
e se esse trabalho mostrou pra turma que
como grupo eles se completam
eu não estou falando quem os meus alunos
que estão presentes aqui sabem disso eu
costumo falar isso em aula
a gente tem que valorizar cada vez mais
as nossas habilidades as nossas
diferenças são as nossas diferenças que
nos tornam interessantes para as outras
pessoas
isto vai lá se reúne com um monte de
gente todo mundo igual
quem não tem diferencial não tem não tem
que não se destacar em relação aos
outros só eu não estou aqui querendo
reinventar a roda não tô querendo propor
uma mudança drástica no sistema de
educação
longe disso questões objetivas ainda são
que as questões que definem o nosso
futuro profissional
a gente tem que ficar muito bom nas
questões objetivas
a gente tem que treinar cada vez mais a
gente não pode continuar elas de forma
alguma a capacidade de interpretação a
capacidade de escrita ela tem que ser
muito exercitadas mas na minha opinião a
gente tem que exercitar muito mais a
nossa capacidade criativa
a gente tem que ser capaz sim de repetir
tem que ser capaz também de produzir de
criar
quando a gente cria algo a gente se
apropria do conhecimento um filho nosso
eu fiz aquele trabalho do zero ele é meu
se alguém por algum motivo criticar o
meu trabalho eu vou lá e vou querer
defender meu trabalho eu fiz ele ele é
meu
esse trabalho acabou demonstrando esse
tipo de avaliação acabou demonstrando
que os alunos também se apropriavam
muito do conhecimento porque a maioria
dos trabalhos apresentavam metáforas
então apresentavam o conteúdo através de
metáforas ou metáfora uma metáfora na
minha opinião é uma das formas mais
complexas de expor um conteúdo que tem
que pegar um conceito de algo e transpor
esse conceito para uma outra situação
isso é muito complexo o aluno só
consegue fazer isso quando ele entende
realmente o que o conteúdo está dizendo
é e as metáforas então aparecem
geralmente na maioria dos trabalhos
claro que no começo muitos muitos alunos
tinham resistência pra se deixar como eu
costumo falar sair da casinha né parar
de de repetir a forma tradicional é de
de passar por uma avaliação
alguns alunos e resistência uma vez eu
escutei de holanda como falei antes
daquela não sabe lidar com liberdade
pessoal a gente é formatado para repetir
somos formatados para repetir e deu pra
perceber que esse trabalho é uma maneira
de incorporar a criatividade e as
habilidades individuais no processo de
aprendizagem é infelizmente não queria
mostrar alguns trabalhos mas é o tempo é
meio restrito mas e pequenos exemplos
teve um trabalho que apresentou as
teorias sobre a origem da vida através
de um jogo de pôquer que acontecia entre
deus que apresentou o cristianismo morte
que apresentou a biogênese um alien que
apresentou avanço permitia e um
cientista que apresentou a evolução
molecular
foi um trabalho muito criativo um
trabalho que é inovador na minha opinião
eu não tinha visto nada parecido até
então portanto nós também somos
surpreendidos
os resultados são muito interessantes
pessoal para encerrar eu tenho uma dica
pra vocês aceitem suas habilidades
aceitem os seus diferenciais
eles estão aí você não conseguir fugir
deles podem até tentar mascarar a mas
não conseguiu fugir
aceitem exercitem as suas habilidades
só para finalizar eu tenho uma pergunta
pra fazer pra vocês
no que vocês são bons
pessoal esse é o recado tá é muito
obrigado pela atenção